hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're gonna
be continuing our coverage the match of
the century that's the 1972 World Chess
Championship between Bobby Fischer and
the defending champion but a Spassky
were in game 12 today to give you a
recap of where we've been so far but
he's basking won game 1 Bobby Fischer
forfeited game 2 they somehow convinced
him to come back and continue the
tournaments he went on kind of a run
winning most of the games there were
some ties here and there three to be
exact and then we get to game number
eleven that we just went over in the
last video I am but in Spassky won that
one so Bobby Fischer has a full two
point advantage six and a half points to
Buddy spassky's four and a half points
you get one point for a win half a point
for a draw so coming into this he feels
confident he has a good lead but he has
the white pieces and he kind of wants to
prove his opponent that the last game
was somewhat of a fluke so Bobby Fischer
starts out with white pieces pawn to c4
not our normal opening we see from Bobby
Fischer he's more of an aggressive
player pawn to e4 but decides to play
that pawn to c4 pani 6 9 f3 pawn down
here to d5 and then pawn d4 and this is
getting into the Queens gambit Klein
line something that Bobby Fischer didn't
really play in a competitive setting
before this tournament so I'm not even
sure if it was he just had tons of
preparation so we just thought hey he'll
never expect us for me and I really have
these great variations I want to throw
at him or maybe it's a psychological
showing his opponent that I can play a
line I'm not necessarily as comfortable
as you are because beneath Spassky very
familiar with the Queens gambit declined
line in high-level play and just kind of
rub it as an opponent's face that I can
play this line and still be better than
you even though I don't know it as well
as you but after a pawn to d4 Knight f6
a knight c3 Bishop here to e7 Bishop to
g5 this is the main line that Bobby
Fischer's getting into upon to h6
so now we have buddy Spassky kind of
getting getting into the TMB system very
solid defense from black Bishop back
here to h4 Castle on the kingside punt
up here to e3 solidifying his pawn chain
and now black has a couple options as
far as how you wants to
continue he decides to go and continue
with the Knight to d7 Bobby Fischer rook
here to see once getting a little more
centrally located pawn to c6 getting
into that scimitar slava a line usually
the bishops gonna be out here to f5 but
instead he's gonna be looking to put it
here on b7 control this long light
square diagonal Bishop up here at d3 we
see a capture and then a recapture on a
c4 and if you're kind of curious in this
particular opening why would just black
give up his central pawn right here well
he's letting white use a lot of his
bishop moves so that he can start to
develop on the Queen side he moved one
move to d3 then he recaptured here on c4
and now black can play pawn to b5 forced
the bishop back to d3 and black does
kind of gain a tempo here as he starts
to develop a little bit more on at the
Queen side of the board a six for the
longest time was thought to be the the
main line the best move over time it
developed into this Bishop to b7 was a
stronger move and then you have
something as recent as 2013 where you
had vision on instead of playing upon a6
or Bishop to b7
he played Bishop here to d6 and he
played this against Levon Aronian in the
Tata Steel tournament in 2013 ended up
going on to win that game so interesting
you know moves that black has that he
can go ahead and try but in this
particular game he decides to play with
what he knows and that is just a pawn
here to a six now pawn up to a four
anytime you see your opponent start to
push on one side of the board
particularly the Queen side you want to
put a halt to that you don't want him
just marching up your side of the board
start to put a strong attack so pawn to
a4 says yeah I like to to counter that
in some way and just see what you do but
he Spassky takes what I think is the
worst line out of all and he plays pawn
takes on a4 he's not necessarily
required to take this pawn this gives
him an isolated pawn here on the C file
which I don't particularly like I think
if the Ponte
on b5 he has a lot of great options to
recapture I think that would be stronger
play he couldn't even play just pawn to
b4 if he wanted to push in that regard
he could just play pawn or Bishop to b7
if he wants to get even crazier a little
frisky play pawn to c5 just really
starting to break up the center of the
board could even just play rook to e8
just not even worry about what's going
on I start to develop his pieces like he
normally would but instead decides to
play pawn takes on a4 and then Knight to
a4 Queen to a5 a check and white has a
few options he decides to go ahead and
play Knight to d2 could have also played
Knight to c3 blocking it from here you
could see rook over to b8 attacking the
pawn may be Queen e2 defending the pawn
here on b2 a Bobby Fischer may have just
looked at this and said I don't want to
worry about that I would rather my
knight here on a 4 defend this square
here on b2 so I'm just gonna keep this
here and I'll go and play Knight to d2
Spassky plays Bishop to b4 why it's kind
of forced to play Knight to c3 stopping
the attack and then pawn c5 and from
here you can kind of see birdie Spassky
part of this preparation was to make
sure that he does not have his isolated
pawn here decides to go ahead and
exchange that for breaking up white
center of the board he would really like
to go ahead and take here on d4 and then
white recapture have his own isolated
pawn Bobby Fischer does not want to do
that so he rightfully plays Knight to b3
this both attacks the pawn attacks the
queen forces it to go back and also
defends the center of the board so if
there is an exchange he can take back
with this Knight and not leave himself
with an isolated pawn in the center
Queen comes back here to d8 castle on
the Kings side then we see exactly what
we talked about pawn takes and the
night's gonna recapture here and then
finally black plays Bishop to b7 thought
he would play it a lot earlier but on
the 18th move decides to go ahead and
play that Bishop to b7 so really trying
to eye down the this entire long
diagonal which is very important Bobby
Fischer says yeah I'm ok exchanging if
you want to go ahead and do that right
now we
can do that this night can't move
because it's being pinned down by the
bishop Queen would fall so he really is
just asking do you want to exchange
light to her bishops right now but he
spassky's not into it decided to go and
play Queen over here to b7 so if there
is an exchange he can recapture with his
queen Bishop to g3 attacking the Queen
there is a little bit of maneuvering
back and forth and then Knight up here
to c6 attacking the Queen just says hey
I'm gonna put you in an awkward position
but he's basket this position decide to
go ahead and exchange but this does
leave Bobby Fischer devil Bishop here
which is exactly what he likes and so he
has a lot of fighting opportunities with
these two bishops we're over here to c8
forcing the bishop to come back decides
instead play Knight to a4 opening up the
door for this rook on c1 to defend this
Bishop rook to d8 just trying to get in
the center of the board and controlled
as much as possible Bishop back here to
f3 upon to a 5 has the outpost for this
Bishop here on a b4 and then work up
here to c6 and this is an interesting
move ayat if you were to just pause this
and say can you find the movie that
Bobby Fischer is going to do
I don't know that rook to c6 is gonna
even be on my top five list of moves
that I would expect him to see I could
easily see pawn to h3 I could see Queen
to b3 continuing his pressure on the
bishop here on b4 this all makes a lot
of sense to me you can even see things
like just rook takes on c8 say don't
really care I'm just going in exchange
if he wants to be a little bit more
aggressive on the King side he can even
play pawn to h4 but rook to c6 is
somewhat surprising just didn't expect
to see it we do see an exchange on board
Bishop takes on c6 a Bobby Fischer
allowing for an exchange on board to
kind of whittle down material he doesn't
have a material advantage he does have
his two bishops but he wants to make
sure that he can hang it onto some
material so doesn't get to the end game
and he's kind of looking there trying to
figure out where his advantage went rook
to a c8 s forcing the bishop
back here to f3 Queen a six and then
pawn to h3 does solidify this square
here on a g4 a little bit but beyond
that's not doing too much Queen to be
five attacking the Knights a bishop back
here to e two attacking the Queen R and
the Queen here on d1 is protecting this
at some point he will probably want to
play pawn to B 3 so we can activate his
Queen a little bit more it is playing
more defensive now then Bobby Fischer
would like Queen back here to a c6 and
then Bishop f3 we see this kind of dance
back and forth and the bishops moving
the Queen moving around from here we see
Queen back here to be 5 and then pawn to
b3 so there's an outpost the queen is
allowed to now move about to
butt-buddies basky says not so fast I'm
gonna bring my bishop back here to e7
discovered attack with the Queen on this
pawn and so now Bobby Fischer is forced
again to kind of have the Queen here to
defend this pawn or move the Queen away
so it doesn't have to worry about an
attack on at the b3 square but these
Caskey plays a Queen to b4 just getting
out of the way of the Bishop Bishop up
here to a6 rook to c6 needs to get out
of the way Bishop comes back here to d3
thought he might play Bishop to c4 it
does block off a lot of blacks move and
as is lysyl outpost but decides to go
ahead and instead play it back here to a
d3 now Knight to a d5 or c5 this is
putting more pressure on this isolated
pawn here on b3 both the Queen and the
knight are attacking it decides to
instead not even worry about it play
Queen up here to f3 and then the RIC
comes back here to see a this is one of
those where when you see your opponent
clearly recognize that you're attacking
a square and he kind of moves away from
it almost baiting you to go ahead and
take that you kind of get concerned like
wow am I missing something if I do take
this or my piece is gonna fall am I
gonna end up losing because I think he
had a stronger move if he didn't even
look at this rook and said let's just go
ahead and block this off I can play
Knight to
efore here then kind of what happens
here that the pawn is still under attack
this is putting a lot of pressure on his
opponent if it moves his queen back you
can always take here on g3 give his
opponent not the best position on the
kingside the boar as far as a pawn
structure you'll have an isolate a pawn
here on e3 as well if Bobby Fischer
decides to take Bishop on e4 then just
the night takes and then what's white
kind of sat with now we have the same
issue as before Black has a very
aggressive rook in the center of the
board he can no longer has to worry
about the the paired bishop for Bobby
Fischer and he even has this strong
attack on the square on b3 so I think
hastily he moved that rook to a c8 don't
think he had to but Bobby Fischer
decided okay after I see this I'm gonna
go ahead and take this material here the
bishop comes back rook over here to see
one and then rook to the a and this is
kind of a a trap as well if you look at
and say well why wouldn't he just take
the pawn here on b3 well the rook can
freely take on c5 the rook can no longer
recapture because you'll have a mating
opportunity queen up here it's a eight
the what's key here is the King can't
come here to h7 because of the bishop on
d3 so there's a few moves that you can
have just to kind of make this last a
little bit longer rook up here to c8 but
eventually it is going to be a checkmate
so what looks like kind of a mistake to
just give up that pawn it's actually a
trap but e Spassky does not fall for it
he plays rook over here to d8 and says
yeah if I'm gonna go ahead and take your
pawn you could take my bishop I'll take
your bishop no big deal I'm not too
worried about it
and then as king would freely be able to
come here to h7 Bobby Fischer continues
with Bishop to c4 the outpost I thought
he would have a long time ago Queen down
here to d2 rook over here f1 Bishop to
b4 and we have two low Q outposts next
to each other they are on the outskirts
not really doing a ton if they were in
the stern of the board they could
control a little bit more but now Bishop
over here to c7 attacking the rook rook
down to d7
queen up to c6 both sides trying an
attack they just don't have enough
material really that they can do to push
an advantage
Bishop down here to e5 rook down to d2
always want to get your rooks to your
opponent's second-ranked but there's
just not enough attacking very easy to
defend just against the rook and the
Queen when you have your own major
pieces on board as well
Queen over here to a8 now the King can
come to h7 as we talked about there's an
exchange on board Queen back here to f3
pawn to f5 pawn up here to g4 say let's
go ahead and break this up Queen here to
e4 says if you want to exchange that's
fine with me King down to g6 getting a
little bit more involved into the game
while there is major pieces with the
Queen's and the rooks this definitely is
approaching the endgame because all of a
sudden you could have some exchanges on
board and then you want your king in the
center involved into the action rook
over here to see one Bishop to a3 it
does have this outpost but all of a
sudden it's moving away just to attack
its opponent rook over here to a1 easily
comes back to before the outpost very
easy now the bishop comes up here to e7
and this is an interesting move it's not
really forcing white to do anything it's
deviating from the plan I'm just having
a safety over here on the Queen side
there is an exchange on board work over
here to eat one and now rook to f2 and
this is a calculated move after the King
takes now Bishop to h4 King is forced to
move we see the exchange of the Queen's
and then the Bishop takes here on a1
what's interesting to me is but he's
basking in this position decided to take
a draw he's up in material and while he
doesn't have a huge advantage I can't
possibly see that he would ever lose
this and Bobby Fischer one of the best
in-game players in the world especially
with his pawns but I see no reason why
he couldn't try to continue he won the
last game if he could somehow win this
game with the black pieces against Bobby
Fischer I think this would have almost
been a turning point where Bobby Fischer
would have kind of had to rethink a lot
of stuff he'd only have a point
advantage after 12 games and after
losing two games in a row it may have
mess with him quite a bit but buddy
Spassky decided instead in this position
it wasn't even worth to continue and
decided to go ahead and draw so
interesting opening choice for Bobby
Fischer
but at the end of the day he does get
the draw so that's it for game 12
hopefully you guys enjoyed this very
entertaining game from my perspective
even in a draw but we'll go ahead and
get back at it in game 13 but thanks
everyone again for watching I'll see you
guys in the next video